[Music]
Creed 3 is here and not only does
Michael B Jordan reprise the role he
made famous but this time he steps
behind the camera to bring his story to
life and through his personal investment
the ending means more than ever Creed 3C
is now retired Adonis attempt to lead
newcomers to the same greatness he
achieved while maintaining his family
with Bianca however adonis's world is
turned upside down when his old friend
Damian reappears after nearly two
decades in jail although Adonis doesn't
know it at first Damien has revenge on
his mind for something that happened
between them when they were kids their
dramatic Clash leads Adonis to step back
into the ring to face his former friend
Creed 3 finds Adonis on his own to tell
his story without Rocky Balboa by his
side the result is a deeply personal
story in adonis's Arc as he's forced to
face his past with Damien's re-emergence
and deal with the trauma he's tried to
keep hidden the slow burning Feud that
develops between Adonis and Damian
eventually builds toward a brutal fight
for dominance however other parts of
personal story are Unearthed in this
confrontation
throughout the film we're giving
glimpses into the Fateful night that saw
Adonis and Damien's brother-like
relationship come to an end although
Adonis would eventually become the
world-class boxer we know he didn't
start out on that path in reality Damien
was the rising boxing Talent having
already earned some noteworthy accolades
and a few nasty Knockouts Adonis wasn't
much of a fighter and acted more as
Damien's manager or assistant however it
all came to an end on one particular
night in a flashback we see Adonis and
Damien run into their old abusive Group
Home Father Leon Adonis becomes enraged
by the man and starts to beat him up
it's not long before Leon's cohorts rip
Adonis off him but before they retaliate
against him Damien pulls out a gun to
defend his friend unfortunately the cops
pull up shortly after and arrest Damien
while Adonis flees from the scene while
Damian was ready to stand by Adonis
Adonis couldn't do the same and this
moment still affects both men decades
later Damien doesn't have much when he
comes out of prison but the time he's
spent inside has allowed him to develop
a Revenge plot he's ready to act on the
x-cons Swift intelligence is a big part
of what makes him stand out amongst past
antagonists faced by Adonis or even
Rocky I'm coming for everything you
threatening me Damien wastes no time
embedding himself into his old friend's
Inner Circle and even gets into the gym
to train against adonis's Protege Felix
their Damien studies Felix to learn his
techniques when he's ready Damian
convinces Adonis to let the newly freed
boxer to fight adonis's young student
Damien takes things even further by
hiring one of his old prison friends to
beat up adonis's rival turned friend
Victor Drago the conflict results in
Drago's hand being broken which means he
can't fight in an upcoming bout with
Felix Adonis needs this fight with Felix
to happen though so he gives Damien his
shot in the ring although he nearly gets
disqualified for some dirty hits Damien
knocks Felix out and earns his title
then with this new power and influence
he openly torments and calls out Adonis
to damage his reputation and get under
his skin Damien might have seemed
friendly at first to Adonis but he
quickly becomes a rival he can't escape
not long after Damien wins the title
fight against Felix adonis's mother
Marianne calls him to her house to
reveal something devastating upon
arriving Adonis sees letters spread
across the kitchen table all from Damien
it turns out that Damien had been
sending letters to Adonis throughout his
time in prison but Marianne kept them
from him she says that Damian was always
bad news and that she was trying to
protect Adonis from falling into the
same patterns Adonis is infuriated and
incredibly cold towards his mother if
Adonis had known that Damien had been
writing to him there's a good chance he
might have reached out and this war he
now finds himself in with Damien might
have never happened now Adonis is locked
into a fiery battle with Damien while
knowing that there could have been a way
for things to be better realistically
though even Adonis knows that he was
really trying to forget what happened to
Damien all along in the earlier parts of
the film it's mentioned that Marianne
had recently had a stroke that leaves
Adonis and Bianca concerned throughout
the movie Marianne's condition worsens
to the point that Adonis only has time
for one last conversation with her
Adonis and Marianne's final conversation
is easily the tenderest moment of the
film and it's largely because of who
Marianne thinks Adonis is although
Adonis is right in front of her Marianne
talks to him like he's Apollo Creed
adonis's late father for both Adonis and
longtime Rocky fans the mere mention of
Apollo's name might bring a few tears to
the eye because Marianne thinks that
she's talking to Apollo it allows her to
be honest when talking about her love
for Adonis it's a Bittersweet scene
showing how real the emotion is between
mother and son as Damien and adonis's
Feud becomes more intense it makes the
people in adonis's life concerned about
the pain he still Harbors throughout the
film Bianca tries to get Adonis to open
up but he denies her advances they get
into a heated argument right in front of
their daughter Amara however after
Marianne's sudden death leaves him
immensely vulnerable he confides to
Bianca about his past in a tearful
conversation Adonis tells Bianca about
Leon's abuse and the incident that led
to Damien's arrest he talks about how
responsible he still feels for leaving
Damien behind and never reaching out to
him Adonis comes to the realization that
maybe he chose to forget about Damien
because it made it easier to move on
finding a way to confront his past with
Damien and forgive himself is a huge
part of his personal Arc and this is
probably the most open we've seen Adonis
throughout the Creed franchise
with Damien constantly throwing dirt on
his name in the media Adonis is faced
with a tough choice should he step into
the ring with Damien and put an end to
this conflict Adonis tells Bianca that
he doesn't see another way out of this
and she tells him do what you gotta do
finally ready to step into the ring
again to fight Damien Adonis doesn't
announce his intentions in an ordinary
fashion instead Adonis decides to give
Damian a taste of his own medicine and
uses the media to draw him out he
ultimately appears on ESPN's First Take
and gets Damien to call in when I walked
away from boxing I walked away with some
unfinished business
Adonis becomes the kind of tactician
that Damien has been from the start and
essentially draws him into his trap once
Damian gets on the air he starts
berating Adonis with virtually no filter
and Adonis uses it to fuel his fire
right then and there Adonis challenges
Damien to a fight before quickly getting
off the show Adonis goes all out when
challenging Damien and it sets the stage
for a bloody spectacle between the two
with Damien and Adonis ready to Duke it
out on the biggest stage possible we get
what everyone expects from these movies
a huge training montage it's no surprise
to see a Creed movie feature these
intense sequences of Adonis and his
opponent pushing themselves to their
limits before their final bout this time
around we see Damian destroying sparring
partners in the ring and getting into
some tough workouts on the beach Adonis
on the other hand is in a secluded
facility on a mountain sparring with a
now healed Drago and reigniting that
fire within him however there's more
going on in this sequence than just
sweaty workouts throughout the film
Adonis and Damien have been shown in
different lights Adonis lives a life of
luxury while Damien remains rugged and
gritty this reflects how vastly
different their lives and perspectives
have become since they split apart but
here they're reversed Damien trains in
his own gym and looks more glamorous
than he has leading up to this moment it
makes it clear that he's primed to claim
the success he deserves Adonis meanwhile
goes back to his roots in a small
facility he knows that he has to regain
his old Fighting spirit it's a sequence
that's thrilling to watch because of all
the energy pouring out of it but it also
features progression in both Damian and
adonis's Journeys when the time finally
comes for Damien and Adonis to get into
the ring together the tension is higher
than in any of adonis's previous spikes
the Bad Blood between these two has
truly come to a boil and even in the
opening moments of the fight they don't
pull their punches right off the bat
some brutal shots set the tone and it's
only a couple of rounds in before blood
starts to pour there's a moment in the
battle where everyone else in the
stadium disappears and it's just Adonis
and Damian in the ring fighting each
other now go whatever was and walk into
what is it's a visually stunning and
immersive experience sequence throughout
the entire scene you can't help but
wonder how much time has passed by the
time the crowd reappears the two have
reached round 12. the climactic boxing
matches easily one of the most memorable
of the franchise and a great showcase
for Jordan's Direction plus it all
builds towards an unforgettable end
Damien and Adonis hold nothing back in
their big blowout fight and some moments
see them nearly break each other at one
point Damien delivers the strong gut
punch to Adonis and he's brought to his
knees he almost isn't able to beat the
10 count Michael B Jordan has mentioned
on the movie's press circuit that he
took some inspiration from anime for
some of the fight sequences and that
Swift punch to the gut is actually
inspired by a devastating punch from
Goku to Frieza in Dragon Ball Z Damien
gives Adonis a run for his money and
leaves his face a bloody swollen mess
but it's not enough to take him down
Adonis eventually turns the tables on
Damien by pushing him toward the ropes
once he finds a good opening he pops
Damien right in the face and it's not
long before Damian is sprawled out on
the floor knocked out Adonis has finally
defeated Damien and his past demons he's
officially cemented as one of the
greatest fighters of all time and he's
kept The Prestige of the Creed Legacy
intact Adonis defeats Damien in the ring
and keeps his reputation as a top
fighter but there's still more that
needs to be done to end and this
personal Feud after the fight Adonis
goes to Damien to talk with him face to
face with all their anger and rage left
in the ring they can now have an honest
conversation about their unresolved
feelings with Damien humbled in front of
everyone it's safe to say that there's
going to be no more trash talking from
him Adonis and Damien forgive each other
and themselves for what happened the
night Damien got arrested the Stellar
performances from both leads heighten
the emotion as Damien is brought to
Tears by adonis's forgiveness these two
are now able to put the past behind them
after talking with Damian Adonis heads
back to the ring and sees Bianca and his
daughter Amara throughout the film Amara
has shown an interest in becoming a
fighter like her father she watches his
old fights and Donis even shows her some
moves now seeing his daughter Shadow
Boxing in the ring he can't be prouder
to see another chapter in his life
unfolding Adonis jumps into the ring
with Amara to have a little fight of
their own and he lets her win in an
adorable way then he leaves the ring
looking content but wonders if this will
be his last fight whether it'll be
Adonis going back into the ring for
another bout against a new foe or
watching Amara take the Creed Legacy in
her own Direction fighting will always
be a part of who Adonis is with that in
mind seeing him walk out of the ring
after dealing with all these family
troubles and personal demons is more
satisfying than ever
[Music]
foreign